(upbeat music)
(sweet music)
- Hello.
- Salutations.
- Greetings.
Welcome to Walsh on Walsh
where we interview each other...
- About each other...
- [Together] While lying
on top of each other.
- Good to see you, brother.
- Good to see you.
How is it up there?
- It's cold.
- How's the weather?
- Oh, good.
- Yeah.
- It's hot down here.
- But I'm starting to heat up.
- Oh yeah.
- You're hot down there?
- Yeah, can't you feel it?
- You are hot down there.
- Feel my heat.
- (laughing) I can feel it.
- You're going to
steam up your glasses.
- I know.
Have you ever told a lie
and the lie was so bad
that you had to move?
- I've done that twice.
- (laughs) Oh, you have?
- Yeah, once I had to
move, as you well know,
to my favorite place:
Southern New Hampshire.
The other time to California.
So is it okay if I ask
you a few questions?
- Shoot!
- Oh, okay.
Hang on.
I prepared something.
- You have cards?
- Unlike some people...
I come prepared.
What is your favorite wig?
- My favorite wig is
probably the short brown.
- Oh that's a good one.
- I thought you were
going to say curly red.
What is your first love?
- Ooh!
My first love is home invasions.
- Oh.
- (laughs) Yeah.
- Oh that's a good one.
(dramatic music)
- Hey!
- Hi!
How are you?
We're the Walsh Brothers.
- Yeah we used to live
here in this house.
- You remember when we
used to play witch's swamp?
- Oh yeah.
- It was all alligators,
so you gotta...
You're gonna get eaten.
- You're gonna get bit, man.
- Yeah, you're gonna get eaten.
- You're gonna get bit.
When we were here
this was just full
of Dean Koontz novels.
- We called it the
cabinet of Koontz.
This your workout room?
- Is there any
reason why you have
a black dildo up there?
- That's a light bulb...
- Should probably put this back.
- Yeah my grandmother
she died like Elvis,
on the toilet.
And then we buried her
out back like a gerbil.
- Alright, last call boys!
These ashes smell
like catsh- (bleeps)
But I like catsh- (bleeps)
- Hey, it's okay if I'm
watching that lady, right?
- Who let you in?
- Neil?
- Yeah, well we
used to live here.
We grew up in this house.
- Yeah, a lot of good memories.
- Well, welcome back.
- Yeah.
Oh, nice.
(dramatic music)
(upbeat music)
I really like this studio.
- Yeah, it's delightful.
I really like that
wee old british man
sitting on the ladder
having a spot of tea.
- I'm just a little
old english man sitting
on a ladder with my shirt off
having a spot of tea.
- Well you seem a
little sore today.
- Yup.
- I want to know what's
going on with you.
- I'm a little sore.
I've been going to
the gym every day.
And stealing fitness equipment.
- So what are some
of your dislikes?
- One of my dislikes
is I hate people
who cling to old toast.
- You know one of
my favorite things
is when we did that
scavenger hunt.
- Oh, when we hunted scavenges.
- No, we did the
scavenger hunt for points.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
(upbeat music)
Hi we're doing a scavenger hunt.
I'm on a scavenger hunt.
Oh hi!
Can I have a sip of your beer?
- No!
- It's worth like nine points.
- No, it's... that's my beer!
(ringing)
- One of the things
is we have to
take a picture
wearing high heels.
- I mean, if it'll help you win.
(ringing)
- Are you guys brothers?
- Yeah.
- We're brothers!
We've got to take a
picture with brothers.
It's 112 points!
- [Together] Cheese!
(ringing)
- What do you say?
- No.
- You finish that pizza,
and you come touch
dinkies with this guy?
- I'm sorry, what?
- It's for a lot of points.
- Yeah it's seven points.
Oh excuse me sir.
We're doing a scavenger hunt
and we have to take a picture
(ringing)
of eating a hot dog right there.
It's just your cock and balls.
I'd like to see it.
Hi!
Excuse me, Nordic man.
Do you work out?
- Yeah.
- Is it going to be
on the internet, or...
- No, no, no, no, no.
- No, no, no.
It'll be on a scavenger hunt.
- [Together] Shalom.
(ringing)
- Ha, hee, ha ha!
- Say cheese!
(ringing)
- Awesome!
I love your boobs!
You too!
- See you later.
They're beautiful.
- How many points is this worth?
(ringing)
One, two, three.
- [Together] Cheese!
(ringing)
- I have an idea.
- Yeah?
- What if we did Walsh
on Walsh on Walsh
with our brother?
- Are you reading my mind?
- John!
Get in here!
We're in the garage.
- You guys brought me
down here for this?
You two are (bleeps) nuts.
I ain't doing this (bleeps).
- It's just a chat show, John.
- Yeah, about Walshes.
- Yeah.
- It's (bleeps) weird.
- It's not weird.
- No.
- It's just like your macho test
you used to give us.
- It's nothing like
the macho test!
I made you guys eat cat
eggs and drink my urine.
This is (bleeps) weird.
(laughs)
You laugh like you're
(bleeps) mental patients,
the two of you!
Douche!
(ricochets)
(explodes)
I'm (bleeps) out of here!
- Where you goin'?
- Hey, where you going?
- Come on!
- Oh!
What a strange man that
brother of yours is.
- Well, anyway.
Thanks again for joining us
for another exciting
episode of Walsh on Walsh.
- Goodbye, everybody.
(laughs)
- Oh, you done watching
the video, huh?
- Oh, you're done are ya?
- Are you done?
Oh, well here's a
little recommendation.
We got a secret button.
Roll on over...
And click on the secret...
Roll on over!
- It's the part where we roll.
That's what he's saying.
- Yeah, it is.